from our hiding place in the sand dunes
we spot a boat not heading out from
calais but arriving on its shores
it came in slowly there was no sound of
an engine
the group carried the motor from the
vessel and hide behind huts
seemingly uncertain of what to do
as dawn pushes its light into the sky
they leave
and we follow i managed to call out to
one man
he is sudanese and tells me the group
tried to cross the channel but got into
trouble
the fuel ran out the engine failed the
smugglers who provided the boat
cared nothing for their safety how much
did you all pay
[Music]
each person and how many on the boat
how many people
10 people and you all paid 1 200
euros okay the wind and sea carried the
boat and its occupants to blereo beach
west of calais
but adrift in the darkness it could so
easily have been struck by a large
vessel during its two hours at sea
the first police officers we've seen on
the beach turned up to guard the
inflatable
until it can be taken away local
fishermen told us they regularly see
boats packed with people
run out of fuel in the channel they say
it's not the aim of the smugglers to
actually get people to uk shores
but simply into british waters
and those smugglers make more money the
more people they pack into every boat
in a wood east of calais we find a
makeshift camp which dozens of iraqi
kurds call home
as they wait for passage to england it's
where we meet kazan
and his young family he shows us where
they live
primitive by any standard a week ago
they got into a boat to cross the
channel
but kazan soon realized they would
double the number of people on board
than they should have been
he and his family jumped off the ship is
only like
40 percent or only like 30 percent is
going in
but i don't know from who is making the
job 6
60 person 70 person put in the move it's
not
good 70 percent for 7 meter
is not good that's why we come back
as french police try to disrupt the
trade they've been breaking up camps and
moving migrants on
including from an area known as the
jungle where people took their
frustration out on us
as we pass through but the recent
success of so many reaching the uk
has only fueled the desire for others to
follow
we're back at blerio beach for a second
night where our thermal imaging camera
captures
six people hiding in the dunes it's a
spot where migrants wait for the call
from smugglers
to say a boat is coming this would not
be their moment
no boat arrived and they disappeared off
into the shadows
few here doubt they'll be back michelle
clifford sky
news cali